Miley Cyrus you designed her engagement  ring in 2012 just been spotted Missy  with a shirt wearing a certain ring that  looks awfully similar to said engagement  ring is that the ring well you know  sometimes when it looks like it and  looks like it looks like it it it looks  like it from the picture it was designed  in gold that a wonderful old cushion cut  diamond it's got a beautiful engraving  in the gold mounting it looks just like  it what do you remember from designing  that ring with William it was really  special  I found the 19th century stone really  really pretty a bit of magical stone and  he wanted something in gold he wanted  something really special and like  one-of-a-kind really really special